غير بعيد عن موقع الزلزال
تضميض لجراحم النجو من الماسه
سماح سوريا متطوعه بالدفاع المدني تعمل مع
رفاقها متنقله من موقع الى اخر
تداوي جرحا وفي النفس جرح لا يظهر رغم
مصابنا بان فقدنا بيوتنا من وفقدنا احد
المتطوعات معنا بالمركز توجهنا توجهنا
لعمليات البحث والانقاذ وبعد ما انتهينا
توجهنا لمراكز الايواء وعم نساعد الناس
يلي متضررين بالزلزال
وجه اخر اوجه التكافل الاجتماعي بين
السوريين يظهروا هنا
فتاخر المجتمع الدولي في تقديم العون
لمنكوب الزلزال دفع مجموعه من المتطوعين
الى انشاء مطوخ ميداني
هي محاوله يسد ثغره وافساح المجال
للمنكوبين اذا لملمه جراح اخرى تركها
الزلزال لما شفنا اثار الدمار في مدينه
جنديرس وشفنا فرق الانقاذ تواصل الليل
بالنهار
بعملها من اجل انتشال الاحياء خطر بان
نقوم بمطبخ ميداني في مدينه جنديرس لانه
ما حدا بلشان فيهم اكيد
بالاطعام الليلي يعني خصوصا ما حدا راح
يفضى لهم فخطر ببالنا المطعم المطبخ
الميداني وكان دعمه طبعا من مبادرات اهليه
محليه
ولان كثيرا ممن شردهم الزلزال باتوا بلا
ماوى حتى الان
ياتيهم العون محليا هذه المره بل شو تركيب
شباب
فالاولوية لعبد الله ومن معه
هي تامين خيام المشردين احنا
منظمه ولا جمعيه ولا مساعدات دوليه هاي
كلها جهود فرديه وشخصيه وجهودها لنا
واصدقائنا واللي قلبهم علينا عم يساعدونا
هاي المساعدات فنحن امكانياتنا على قدنا
[موسيقى]
عمر الحوراني الجزيره من مدينه جنديرس في
حلب